[Musique]
au kamouraska dans le bas-saint-laurent
le temps s'accroche surtout à la tête
d'al humaine la microbrasserie de
saint-andré où on aimait tirer les
journées d'été si en savon la bière
locale avec des saucissons secs mais pas
n'importe lesquels des soucis 100
fabriqué ici les amateurs de charcuterie
fine connaissent bien les saucissons
secs apporter d'europe comme la rose est
de lyon où le soufre esata italien ils
sont toutefois de plus en plus nombreux
à découvrir et adopter des saucissons
secs fabriqués par des artisans
québécois comme ceux des cochons tout
rond ceux ci sont de toute façon
reithalle une viande biologique
charlevoix qui n'ont rien à envier à
leurs cousins européens
johan est propriétaire du fou du cochon
à la pocatière
ces produits sont aujourd'hui la fierté
de la région le québécois de souche en
campagne je sue sont secs
on connaissait pas ça puis on était les
larves hâtive par rapport à ça parce
qu'il ya une flore parce que c'est
bizarre parce que c'est c'est que ces
crues beaucoup de craintes on a dû
défaire beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
paradigme en fait pas réparation
un souci son sexe et du para chez auquel
on ajoute du sel ou des nitrites des
épices puis des ferments lactiques pour
développer une flore bactérienne comme
estives le mélange est ensuite poussé
dans des boyaux
mais ceux ci sont sont entreposés en
salle d'affinage ou le séchage
développera arômes et saveurs
[Musique]
un des pionniers dans le domaine du
saucisson sec
le fou du cochon est devenu maître dans
l'art de l'affinage comme le temps passe
les soucis sont les petites pièces
environ 30 jours des fois un petit peu
plus on va en aidant les plus grosses
pièces où on peut avoir cinq mois sept
mois d'affinage
contrairement à la saucisse qui doit
être cuite de saucisson sec est un
aliment vivant comme le fromage
l'affinage c'est l'étape cruciale et
ultime de sa fabrication
on va perdre de l'eau le produit ici il
va perdre 50 % du poids et une flore
microbienne qui va s'installer sur le
produit tout au long de son affinage
c'est des bons microbes ça c'est des
bonnes bactéries bonne levure bons
champignons la salle d'affinage du fou
du cochon est équipé d'étagères en bois
d'érable une grande fierté pour nathalie
l érable vient jouer sur la saveur pour
avoir un goût particulier propre à
[ __ ] cochon qu'ici
boehler anciens qui est si typique en
fait de notre région
[Musique]
au fil du temps la charcutière a créé
des liens avec des artisans et
producteurs de la région
on est comme avant c'est plus dans la
saison avec les codes plus fort oui je
vous dis gagné lui fournit des herbes
marines du bas saint laurent comme le
persil mer et la livèche
la livèche elle apporte un aspect iodé
dans le produit est aussi l salle le
produit donc on met moins celle dans le
grelot des battures parce que l'herbe on
va faire le travail de salé si les
saucissons secs de fabrication
artisanale se trouvent surtout dans les
boucheries épicerie fine dans les
grandes surfaces on trouve plutôt des
saucissons de fabrication industrielle
qui sont importés
le québec produit aussi plusieurs soucis
sont en user mais je pense le marché en
général
[Musique]
c'est le cas des aliments roma qui
fabrique des charcuteries depuis plus de
60 ans ici aussi la qualité d'un
saucisson réside surtout dans le temps
d'affinage
un élément qui n'apparaît pas dans la
liste des ingrédients je pourrais le
faire sécher celui là encore on va dire
de moi mais si je le fais sécher en
quatre mois en danse de chant qui
épluche bédard ont fait du
vieillissement aussi bien le gouffre
changé en allemand c'est juste meilleur
avec l'état c'est comme dans le fond le
temps s'est passé devant faire partie
les soucis sont souvent pointés du doigt
par les nutritionnistes
avec raison nos échantillons contiennent
de 300 à 750 mg de sodium par portion de
30 go 750 mg c'est le tiers de la valeur
quotidienne recommandée et pour les gras
saturés
ça varie de 0 5 à 6 g la plupart en
contient autour de 3 g par portion
c'est comme un vieux bourg à 10 % de
gras ou de la crème à café à consommer
avec modération les saucissons secs de
chez nous se taille une place enviable
dans le rayon des produits fins je crois
que comme les bières les fromages à on
voit que les québécois sont de plus en
plus connaisseur mais non ça va être la
même chose avec le saucisson sec j'en
suis persuadé et en même temps ce que ça
va permettre d'avoir de meilleurs
produits de meilleure qualité de
meilleur charcutier
[Musique]